>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> So we're very excited
to be here also.
The Post has been a
very big supporter
of the National Book
Festival for 10 years.
We're a charter sponsor of the
festival and we're thrilled
that we've had such an
amazing turnout today.
And this pavilion is just
full of such excited faces.
It's really great.
I was actually told to do
a one minute introduction
of Katherine Paterson.
And I have to say, I could stand
here for more than a minute
and just list all the
awards that she has won.
That would certainly
make it very easy
but that would be a very
boring little introduction.
So, I'm going to try to
say a couple of things.
She clearly is though a towering
figure in children's literature.
She is a two-time winner
of the Newbury Medal
and the National Book Award for
her titles Bridge to Terabithia,
Jacob I Have Loved, The Great Gilley
Hopkins and the Master Puppeteer.
Her books are almost not
children's literature
because they really do
deal with many themes
that you don't often find
in books for children.
At the same time though,
her characters triumph
in such wonderful ways even if
they are children themselves.
So her treatment of her
characters is really very much
like the treatment of her readers.
She treats them with the
utmost respect and admiration
and that is why she is so loved.
It's no wonder the library
of congress has named her
in 2000, "A Living Legend."
Wouldn't we all like to
be named a living legend
in some point in our life?
And she is currently
the National Ambassador
for Young People's literature.
Please welcome Katherine Paterson.
[ Sound effects ]
>> Katherine Paterson:
Well I cannot believe all
of you have waited this
long on this hot day.
But it's wonderful to see you,
but hasn't it been a great day?
I've just -- I hope you've had half
as good a time as I've had today.
I love this festival and don't tell
anybody, I've been to four of them,
because they try not to
invite people too often.
[Laughter] And I don't want them to
know how often they've invited me.
I'm hoping the list has
been lost or something
so I can come again very soon.
I was told that this afternoon you'd
like to hear about my newest book.
And someone said to
me, "But it's different
from all your other books."
And I said, "Yeah, most of
my books are all different
from every other book."
But this is different because
I'm writing about a country
that I've never been to and
about people who speak a language
that I've never spoken, and
I've never done that before.
I wrote this book called The Day
of the Pelican because one Sunday
after church, Steve Dale, who's
also in the choir said to me,
"I think you should write
about the high Jews."
Now over the many years that I've
been a writer I cannot tell you how
many times someone has come to me
and said, "I've got a great idea
for you to -- for a book.
All you have to do is write it."
[Laughter] To which I've
said and I hope politely,
"I think that's our idea.
I think you should write it."
[Laughter] But I was
looking for an idea
at that time for a newspaper serial.
Some years ago Ava, the young adult
writer got a bunch of involved
in what we call breakfast serials.
And you write a chapter every week
for the newspapers who subscribe
and of course you have
to end every page,
every chapter with a cliffhanger
so they'll buy the paper next week.
But, because newspaper
space is limited,
each chapter is only three
double-spaced pages long.
So three double-spaced pages,
ending in a cliffhanger
and about fifteen chapters of
that and I thought about it
and I thought well so much
was happening in Kosovo back
in the late 90's I think I could
make three pages of the cliffhanger
out of that if I did
plenty of research.
So three pages and
fifteen chapters of it
and I felt pretty good about it.
It went around to about
100 newspapers
and people seemed to
respond positively.
But my editor Virginia Buckley, who
has been my editor since 1970 said
to me, "I think you should
turn that story into a novel."
I said, "Virginia I can't do that.
I can do three pages and a
cliffhanger and for that I had
to do two years of research.
I don't know how the people talk.
I don't know what they wear.
I don't know what they eat."
And she said, "Well I
think you really should try
because it's a story
that people need t hear."
So I did more research,
but really to prove
to Virginia that it was impossible.
I went to the internet and began
looking for pictures of Kosovo.
And I found almost 200 absolutely
gorgeous pictures taken by a man
who called himself, "Kosovo Cajun",
which sounded like a
very interesting name.
So I emailed Kosovo Cajun who turned
to be a man named Mark Orphila,
naturally from Louisiana but Mark
had lived for seven years in Kosovo.
He knew the language.
He knew the people very well.
He and his wife had worked
in a Macedonian refugee
camp during the worst
of the tragedy and he loved Kosovo.
So I told him what my problem was.
I said I'm desperate to find
someone who will help me because all
of attempts, the Haxhiu family
had long ago moved away from Berry
and all of my attempts to get
in touch with other refugees
from Kosovo who had failed -- I live
in Vermont so it sort of limits you,
although we do have a lot
of refugees in Vermont.
So I asked him a couple of questions
which he immediately answered
and that gave me a hope to
ask him to read my drafts
and help me not make any horrible
mistakes as a I wrote the story.
So the second email
he wrote me he said,
"You know when I answered your first
email I'd never heard of you before.
But I mentioned you to
my wife and my mother,
his mother had been a school
librarian [Laughter] they seemed
to know who you were."
[Laughter] So Mark was the most
wonderful help and you'll notice
that the book is dedicated to him
because I couldn't have
done it without him.
I would write a chapter
and I would email it to him
and of course my chapter would be in
black and he would reply paragraph
by paragraph in red and the
black paragraph was this long
and the red paragraph was this long.
And we just kept working until
there was no more red on the page.
So I owe everything to Mark.
He was wonderful.
Sometimes he would give me
answers that I didn't want to hear
because I thought something
else would be more dramatic
but we were determined
to keep the book as true
to the actual events
as we possible could.
I'm going to read -- I know there's
somebody that's going to flash cards
at me and tell me when to shut
up and I do want to leave time
for questions but I'd
like to read a little bit
from the book if that's alright.
And it's not quite fair
because I'm going to read way
over towards the end of the book.
But I want to do that because I
think perhaps this is the thing
that's most important for us to
think about in this day and time
when we are having all kinds of
problems with not only refugees
and immigration but our whole
attitude towards the people
of Muslim faith is
being sorely tested.
So the Lleshi family has
gone through all kinds
of terrible events in
their native Kosovo.
They've been in a Macedonian
refugee camp and then a church
in Vermont has sponsored
them to come to this country.
They are settling in,
they've been here
about two years and
then the sky falls.
At home they watched on television
as the plane hit the second tower
over and over again and as both
towers crumbled to giant piles
of debris over and over
again their throats were dry.
They could not speak
or look at each other.
"Turn it off", Baba commanded.
He had been sent home
from work early.
No one had come to the restaurant.
Everyone in America was
at home watching the planes
crash and the towers fall.
Did they eat that night?
They must have but afterward
Meli couldn't remember eating,
just the replay of the planes
crashing and the towers falling.
Even with the screen black the image
of the disaster played
on in her mind.
After Vlora and the younger
boys were put to bed,
Mehmet turned the TV on again.
That was when they heard the news
that the whole world now knew.
The terrorists who had crashed
the planes into the twin towers
and blown open the
pentagon were all Muslims.
Baba shook his head in disbelief.
"This is not the way of
the prophet", he said.
"This is sickness, madness."
The next day going to
her locker Meli realized
that people were staring at her.
And then after passed lots
of students in the halls,
there was silence and
then a whispered exchange.
She was used to people not speaking
to her, but this was different.
Everyone is upset.
We're all afraid.
A number of people had
stayed home fearing somehow
that the terrorists would
find their way to Vermont
and bomb the largest
building in their town,
which was the high school.
And over a little way,
they go to their sports.
They're both wonderful
soccer players.
The principal announced over
the PA system that classes
and activities would go on as usual.
But nothing felt usual.
During soccer practice no
one passed her the ball.
She tried to pretend that she
didn't notice the strange looks sent
her way.
Once she found herself
sprawling on the field.
No one had meant to
trip her had they?
But later as she showered she could
hear one of the seniors talking.
It was Brittany, the
varsity goal keeper.
She seemed to be talking loudly on
purpose so that Meli couldn't help
but hear her over the
noise of the water.
"That's what her family
is", Brittany was saying.
"She's one of them, her and
that weird brother of hers."
"No", someone protested,
"She's okay."
"Just ask her", Brittany
said, "You'll see."
Should she just stay in the
shower, pretend she heard nothing,
but that seemed cowardly.
Meli turned off the water, wrapped
her towel around herself and stepped
out into the locker room.
It was as if someone had
pushed the mute button.
No noise, just stares.
Brittany, the only
fully dressed girl
in the room gave Rachel a shove.
"Go ahead ask her."
Rachel who'd been trying to put on
her jeans nearly fell on her face.
She caught at her balance
and then glanced back
at Brittany before turning
red-faced toward Meli.
"Someone said you were
one of them Meli",
she said her voice hardly
more than a whisper.
"That's not true is it?"
"What do you mean them", Meli
asked, "I don't understand."
She looked from one
team member to another,
"If you mean what nationality,
I am Kosovar."
"Well what's that", Brittany asked.
"It's not Christian is it?"
"No." Her throat was so tight
that she could hardly speak.
"No Serbs are Christian.
I am not a Serb -- I --
my family is Albanian.
"I thought you just said Kosovar."
Brittany's eyes narrowed to a slit.
"Yeah, Meli."
It was Chrystal, the junior
whose place Meli had taken
on the Varsity squad.
"What are you really?"
"I told you, I'm Albanian Kosovar."
Come on Meli.
Brittany stepped around
Rachel and glared at Meli.
"You are one of them
you know you are."
"Explain what you mean them."
Of course, by now Meli knew
full well what Brittany
and the others meant by them.
But she wanted to make Brittany
say it out loud to her face.
"How am I one of them?"
She leaned so close to Brittany
that she could see the pimples
on the girls cheeks set to explode.
Brittany straightened,
"Like the terrorists",
she stepped back slightly.
"You know, like their religion."
"I'm not a religious person."
Meli walked over toward
her locker and opened it.
"I told you she wasn't Christian."
"I'm not a religious person"
Meli continued keeping her eyes
on her locker and her voice
as steady as she could.
"But if I have to choose Christian
or Muslim, the okay, I'm Muslim."
She turned around, "But that
doesn't make me one of them.
I'm not a terrorist."
Brittany shoved Rachel
forward once more.
Meli wrapped her towel more
tightly around herself and looked
into the face of the girl she
had thought of as her friend.
Rachel looked everywhere
except at Meli.
"As her about her brother
Rachel", Brittany demanded.
"Ask if he's a terrorist."
"It is not terrorist to want
to fight for your homeland."
As soon as the words were out of
her mouth Meli knew she should never
have said them.
Rachel backed away, her eyes wide.
"See", Brittany yelled so loud her
voice reverberated around the tiles.
"See. I told you."
She whirled around toward
the locker opening the door.
She grabbed her book
bag and threw it
over her shoulder before she
turned again toward Meli.
"Why don't you and your brother
just go back to where you came from?
We don't want any Muslim
terrorists around here."
With that she slammed
her locker shut
and marched out of the locker room.
For a few minutes, they
all stared at the door
as it swung behind Brittany.
And then careful not
to look Meli's way,
everyone finished dressing
quickly and left,
leaving Meli standing their
alone shivering in her towel.
Pull yourself together,
get dressed, go home.
She was thinking in Albanian.
How long had it been
since she'd done that?
She thought in Albanian
only when speaking to mama
and Baba, never in school.
She smiled grimly then --
carefully methodically --
dried herself and put
on her street clothes.
Next she gathered up
her practice uniform,
her freshly laundered game uniform,
her shin guards and her mouth guard
and took them all through the
swinging door to the coach's office.
She carefully folded her
practice uniform into a square
and laid everything down on the
desk in a neat stack with a sheet
of paper torn from her notebook.
She scribbled a short
note for Mrs. Rogers
and laid it on top of the pile.
The she walked out of the school
door into the crisp autumn air.
Mehmet was waiting for her
as he used to back in Kosovo.
She could see that someone
had bloodied his nose.
He had tried to wash it away
but there were still traces
of blood around the nostrils.
She did not have the
strength to ask him why.
They walked home in silence.
Mama and Baba were both home.
There was no work for them that day.
"What happened", mama asked
looking back and forth
from Meli's face to Mehmet's.
"I'm going home", Mehmet said.
Baba turned off the TV and got up.
"What is going on?"
"I'm going home", Mehmet said again.
"I hate America."
Baba put his arm around
Mehmet's shoulder.
"You must tell me what
happened Mehmet."
Mehmet looked at the floor,
"They were all swearing
against the terrorists.
Then they said all
Muslims are terrorists
and Americans must kill them
before they destroy America."
And then Meli could see how close
to tears he was in his anger.
"And then I said, I am
Muslim will you kill me?"
So, he blew out his breath.
So they tried.
He wiped his nose on the back of
his hand making it bleed again.
"I'm never going back
to that school.
They think I'm like
those terrorists.
They hate me."
He looked up defiantly into
Baba's face, "Well I hate them.
We are even."
And then I'm going to
read a little later scene
that takes place that night.
She dimly heard the telephone ring
in the kitchen and didn't think
to wonder who might be calling,
but before long Baba knocked
on her half open door.
"Meli are you dressed?"
"Yes Baba", she whispered
as to not wake Vlora
who was sleeping peacefully
in the other bed.
"Wash your face and comb your hair.
We have visitors coming."
"Visitors, at 9 o'clock at night?"
Then she heard Baba
at Mehmet's door.
She didn't want to
listen to them argue.
She couldn't bear it.
She went quickly to the
bathroom and washed her face.
She patted down her hair and
then went into the kitchen
where mama was busy making coffee.
She had changed into
her nicest dress.
"Mama." "Take some chairs from
the kitchen into the parlor Meli.
We need more chairs in there."
As she was bringing
in a second chair Baba
and Mehmet emerged
from the boy's room.
"Help your sister Mehmet",
Baba said.
Mehmet brought in a
chair and sat down on it,
his body as stiff as a pole.
Meli and mama sat on the others.
She waited for some explanation
from Baba but none came.
At length they could hear
footsteps on the stairs.
It sounded like a number of people.
Police! They're going to
arrest us for being Muslims.
No that was crazy.
Police didn't call ahead
to say they were coming
and mama wouldn't be
dressed up and making coffee
if she thought they were all
going to be hauled off to jail.
It was a ridiculous fear.
Still it was a few seconds
that her heart stopped racing.
Just some of the welcomers, surely.
But why would they
come so late at night.
At the knock Baba nodded at Meli
so she got up and opened the door.
The first person she saw in the
dark hallway was Mrs. Rogers.
Just behind her was Mr.
Marcello and with them Adona.
Why was Adano here?
They hadn't needed a
translator for months.
Mehmet or she or one of the
other children had done all
of the translating
for their parents.
The three visitors were in the
process of taking off their shoes.
Adano must have told the others too.
Americans didn't seem to
know how important that was.
"Let the guests in Meli", Baba said.
He and mama stood up.
When Mehmet saw his coach
he started for his bedroom
but mama grabbed his arm.
"How are you Meli?",
Mrs. Rogers asked.
Meli tried to smile back,
but her face felt frozen.
Adano stepped forward and
said to Adano in Albanian,
"These are the children's
coaches for playing soccer."
She introduced Mrs. Rogers and
Mr. Marcello to mama and Baba.
The adults shook hands formally.
Then Baba indicated that everyone
including Mehmet was to take a seat.
The three guests sat
down on the couch.
"I have made coffee",
mama said shyly to Adano.
"Should I bring it out?
We don't have any cola or mineral
water but" -- Adano shook her head.
"I don't think so", she said.
"It's late.
They won't stay long."
Mr. Marcello was sitting on
the edge of the couch cushion.
He had taken off his baseball
cap and was playing with it.
The light from the ceiling fixture
seemed to bounce off his bald scalp.
Finally without looking
at Baba he spoke to Adano.
"Tell Mr. Lleshi", the coach
said, "That I've come to apologize
for what happened to his son today."
Adano translated.
Mehmet sat like a stone on the
kitchen chair, his lips tight,
a bruise on his face dark
against his red cheek.
Meli could still see the
dried blood in his nostrils.
"Tell him", the coach continued,
"That it will never happen again.
I will not tolerate
this kind of behavior.
Tomorrow those boys are
off the team for good."
As Adano translated, Meli
saw Mr. Marcello had a hole
in one of his socks.
She could see his big toe
sticking out like a tiny bald head.
Poor man, she thought, how
hard this must be for him.
She glanced at Mehmet to see if
he felt any pity for his coach.
If he did, there was no sign of it.
"And you should tell Mr. and
Mrs. Lleshi that I totally agree
with Coach Marcello",
Mrs. Rogers said.
I'm cutting every girl who
took part in that scene
in the locker room today.
But that would be the
whole team Meli thought,
and then wondered how her coach
had found out what had happened.
Someone must have been
ashamed and told her.
Meli hoped it had been Rachel.
"I should have been there.
I'm usually just next
door in my office
but I had been called
to the main office.
So I wasn't there when it happened.
Otherwise, I cannot tell
you how sorry I am."
Baba listened, his head
bent towards the translator
to make sure he understood
every word.
When Adano finished, he
looked up at the coaches.
"Thank you", he said.
Then he turned back to Adano,
"Tell the kind teachers
that it would not be a good
thing to remove those boys
and girls for all the more.
Tell the teachers that
my children are strong.
They have endured many hard
things in their short lives.
They can also endure this."
He waited for Adano to
say the words in English.
When she paused, he continued.
"Tell them my children wish to
be respected as fellow teammates
and not despised because
of their heritage.
This is the way of the old country.
This is America, tell them.
In America everyone
has a new beginning."
When Adano finished translating,
Mrs. Rogers smiled first
at Baba and then at Meli.
"And what about you
Meli", she asked softly.
"Do you agree?
Shall I let everyone
stay on the team?"
"Yes, like Baba said."
"Even Brittany?"
"You can't have a team
without a goalkeeper."
Coach Marcello turned and
spoke directly to Mehmet.
"What about you Mehmet?
How do you feel about this?"
Mehmet didn't answer.
He sat very still,
his eyes on the floor.
"Tell the teacher", Baba
said, speaking to Adanoa
but looking all the while at Mehmet.
"Tell the teacher that my son had
endured much more painful hardship
than this.
As a child he was once in a
Serbian jail where he was beaten
and left in a field to die."
As Adano translated, Meli saw
Mr. Marcello's eyes widen.
Mrs. Rogers gasped.
"He is very brave, my
son", Baba continued.
"And I'm very proud of him.
He will do the right thing.
You will see."
Now Mehmet looked up at Baba
and for a moment Meli imagined she
saw tears in her brother's eyes.
He did not wait for Adano to finish
her translation before he said
quietly, "Baba is right.
One man does not make a team.
We must play together
or there's no game."
Coach Marcello's hand
stopped fiddling with his cap.
He cleared his throat.
"Thank you Mehmet", he said.
Then quietly so that
Meli did not hear it
until it was repeated
in her own language.
"He says to tell you Mr.
Lleshi that you are a good man
and he hopes he will
be as good a father
to his children as
you are to yours."
"Tell the kind teachers",
Baba answered, "That Mehmet
and Meli will be back
for practice tomorrow."
[Applause] Thank you.
I've been signaled that
we have four minutes
so if I don't make the answers
too long we should have time
for a few questions.
I think there mics in
the aisle if anyone wants
to step up and ask a question.
>> Hi.
>> Katherine Paterson: Hi.
>> I was wondering how you
maintain the authenticity
when you're speaking from the
voice of a child or a young person
and how you maintain
that connection.
>> Katherine Paterson: Oh, how
do I maintain the connection
with the child that
I'm writing about?
>> Yeah, you mentioned a little bit
that you had authenticity talking
about Kosovo and that experience.
And speaking from the perspective
of a young person I'm curious
how you're so authentic.
I really enjoyed reading
your books as a young person
and it really spoke to me.
And I just wanted to
ask how you did that.
>> Katherine Paterson: Thank you.
Well, it's always very mysterious
to me because, see my gray hair.
I don't think I have actually
a very good memory for details
of my childhood and youth,
but I think I have a
good emotional memory.
And that's what I rely
on when I right.
I remember how things felt
and in this book I remember
how it felt to be a refugee.
I remember how it felt to
come to the United States
and be despised by my classmates.
So I think that helped
me in writing the book.
Yes.
>> What is your inspiration for
the book Bridge to Terabithia?
>> Katherine Paterson: I
wrote Bridge to Terabithia
because our son David's
best friend was a girl
and the summer they were both
8 years old she was struck
and killed by lightening.
And it was such a terrible tragedy
that I began to write the book
to try to make sense of a tragedy
that didn't make any sense to me.
I didn't for one minute think it was
going to comfort my grieving son,
but I did think it might help me.
And indeed it's always been a
very hard book for David to read.
I think until he was in his
40's and actually made the movie
that was the thing that helped
him the most, to go back
and revisit the book and
to put in another form.
>> Okay thank you.
And by the way, I liked the book.
>> Katherine Paterson: Thank you.
Yes.
>> Hi I love your books and I was
wondering how long it normally takes
to write your books?
>> Katherine Paterson: Well
it depends on the book.
I did write a book in the shower
once, but that's a record.
I've taken a lot of
showers since then
and no more books in the shower.
But that was really terrific
and it was a fairy story
called The King's Equal.
It just came to me all in a rush.
Usually it takes me -- I used to say
it took me a year now I say year,
two years, three years,
depending on how much research
and also what else is
happening in my life.
How are we doing on time down there?
One more minute?
I guess we have time
for one more question.
>> I love your books.
And what was your reaction
to the people
that bought all your
books so quickly?
>> Katherine Paterson: Oh,
can you think of anything
that would make you happier than
to have them lined up with books
that they had paid for you
to sign that you had written.
You know when I'm in that situation
I just wish all those publishers
that wouldn't publish my
books could be there that day.
[Sound effects] I consider that
the perfect revenge don't you?
I think I have to quite now.
I'm sorry because another
program is coming in.
But thank you so much for your
patience and being with me.
[Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the library of congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.